um break down the title to your album no
stylist yeah just the the it's it's
there's some it's interesting to read
out loud the first one or the the latest
the plus Ultra no yeah yeah well
everything is maximized
Plus
B Orchard B no stylist and my cat name
is ocean so I read your cat Marquette so
you're a cat guy I got cat and dogs nice
what kind of um dogs do you have uh my
dog I don't know why I said dogs but my
dog so you have a dog and a cat yeah
they get along nah but my dog is a
German Shepherd black labrador mix wow I
love German Shepherds and black labs yep
the cat be [ __ ] the dog up though
little key right the cat just stare at
the dog through the window the cat never
does like this they can't touch they the
first time I tried to make them link up
that was bad news oh they ain't [ __ ]
with each other at all it's like it's
like some beef [ __ ] I feel like my dog
kind of like [ __ ] I was here first
right right where are you you feel me
would you pick your cat or your dog
zombie apocalypse zombie apocalypse man
honestly and don't hate me I would pick
my cat just because dogs like literally
can defend themselves fair enough like
that [ __ ] gonna be biting some [ __ ]
well do you remember
um in I Am Legend Will Smith had to
crack his German Shepherd's neck at the
end I cried by that was horrible very
sad that was trash yeah so you would if
you had to save one from becoming a
vampire or a zombie dog let my dog
become a vampire wow what the [ __ ]
that's hard I respect it that's super
hard but then that fool try to kill you
right after bro what
um you're a vampire thank you
it explains the upside down cross
exactly some real vampire what's your
favorite vampire movie
um damn I like
don't judge me I like Twilight
personally but then I like Queen of the
damn Interview with a Vampire that [ __ ]
kind of suspect but I like that movie
too super interview with vampires got a
lot of a lot of a lot of but it's a good
movie that's spicy it's very spicy it's
very sassy it's a good film though yeah
it's a good film you know Queen of the
Damned was the one time I went to a
movie in my life and actually got into a
physical altercation wait in the theater
call us pause pause I lied bro she's a
vampire movie with Jamie Foxx and Snoop
Dogg
oh Netflix was it bones is it bones
bones too or something please
that is the best that's the best I don't
know what it's called bro oh it's the
newer one right yeah yeah
I've ever seen bro you know I couldn't I
couldn't um bring myself to press play
on that one now you gotta watch that bro
you got you gotta watch that seat it's
been it's been rough out here for Jamie
for a while I don't remember the last
good Jamie Foxx movie I guess he made
one though Angola is one of them like is
one of them shits that's just so like
hell it's just like it's a good bad
movie like it's just a good movie you
ever see the Lost Boys yeah Lost Boys my
favorite damn [ __ ] like oh we like Lost
Boys Lost Boys is hard it's cool
what else is a good vampire oh there was
a
the one the little Disney movie about
the little boy that's the vampire all
right you know what I'm talking about
Vampire in Brooklyn with Eddie Murphy
was gas that's crazy I've seen that yeah
do you remember that one I know this
[ __ ] guy over here Brian Gaffey
remembers it
all right so we're giving a 100 Yelp or
uh Rotten Tomatoes review to The Jamie
Foxx nuke movie I'm gonna watch it
tonight 100